[Music]
it was a dark and stormy podcast
we had rand and nick and nico and jake
we were on a trail going somewhere
and then a monster came out of the woods
he was looking really
it was me it was red
it turns out he had bitten himself and
he's one of those special titans and
they get
to uh turn into monsters and things like
that at the same time
super meanie titan all right what's
going on guys
hey what is going on what's going on
thank you for uh
should i turn the noise expression back
off at this point or
no you're good dude there's no noise to
worry about there it's all good crisp
clear audio you may hear children crying
screaming laughing running
things of that nature your children
yes okay just making sure it's got a
collection
yeah yeah most of the time they're mine
i don't know
i don't know who's over here anymore are
your kids old enough to like have like
friends over and stuff now
like play dates yeah they're getting
close we uh we went to a birthday party
the other day for
uh a classmate which was kind of the
first time we'd done that
oh wow um so what's the theme you know
they're getting to the age where that's
happening
uh the theme well okay so big big news
in bernie guys but they built
the aero play plex and this is basically
a giant
jungle gym for children that's is like
i don't know if you guys were ever in
those as kids but it's discovery zone
you can run
everywhere and do whatever you want wow
and uh yeah it would play something you
could
oh yeah great place to be a quid a kid
so
he did that place to be a squid
great place to be a squid i don't know
about that
but yeah man i remember discovery zone
back in the day it was like the coolest
thing
it was there's an unending world of
tunnels and ball pits dude there was
this really dated one from like the 70s
in my hometown
nevada california growing up at this
park called pioneer park it was this old
park with all these like old gravestones
and stuff
they had this big wrought iron metal
play structure
as a kid i remember it being like the
biggest thing in the world
like you'd go up like multiple levels of
ladders on like
with like these like trusses everywhere
and like they're all these like
different like
towers and stuff and the thing is though
it would heat up in the summer
yeah and it would be like deadly
i i distinctly remember being a child
like not even in kindergarten yet and i
remember
getting up into one of those types of
play pins i'm sorry [ __ ] you knocking
over my mind oh
no sorry um and i remember getting onto
the slide and burning myself and then
just
yelling for my mom and eventually she
came over and like climbed up the thing
and carried me down
oh my gosh it was traumatic enough that
i remember it i mean
yeah man kids kids these days you know
they're coddled they're they don't have
like
oven uh play structures they don't have
oven cages
that same park had one of those it was
also like just like
metal so it would heat up one of those
spinny things
where it was uh yeah i go around it was
it's like a death merry-go-round where
it's like
it's basically a hand pan but like
flattened out kind of on the edges
and there's like nowhere to hold on
until you like get like booted off of it
or you throw up
or both yeah and there were some uh
there's some brutal stories and uh
brutal times on that
it was basically like how how long can
you go without getting sick
oh boy um or falling off i don't like
that do you guys did you guys ever go on
like those little like roller pin slides
it was just like a slide with a bunch of
little noodle type cylinders that would
all roll
oh yeah yeah yeah you always get caught
in it somehow
the finger breakers yeah oh my god i'm
glad i didn't break your fingers
timmy went on one of them finger
breakers and look at that oh my gosh
don't cancel me but bill cosby has a
very funny bit
on like play structures when he was a
kid and like how he thinks adults
designed them to kill
kids it's hilarious look it's one of his
old bits
yeah that's about right though man it
makes me think of that
yeah uh hey remember that bike podcast
we did like two weeks ago or three weeks
ago yeah okay
yeah okay update i bought the bike
um so i got i got that fancy new
e-mountain bike this past weekend well
tell me about it we won't we won't bore
you too much
yeah we don't spend too much time on
stuff but like this is a big update
well here's the thing so you know one of
the big aspects of the friendship
between me and ren is our love for
electric vehicles and wacky engineering
and
i we specifically held off on me talking
to ren about this
until live on this podcast he told me
earlier he's like so i got the bike i
was like
you must tell me everything wait wait
wait yes
uh the bike is insane i didn't know bike
technology had like
progressed like outside the electric
side of things just regular bike
technology is
just it's going forward as fast as like
one wheel technology is like stuff's
crazy like so not that fast no i mean
like in the sense that like
i said 23 miles an hour like the last
bike i bought was
six years ago um and i hadn't even
looked at bikes
because i was on the one wheel now for
like the past three years why would you
i mean yeah exactly why would you
um but they've gotten really cool like
you know there's so much like
engineering going into like the geometry
of the bike and the components of the
bike
uh it's just like this thing this this
so that
this bike it's a mountain bike it's one
of like the more modern frame designs
which are built so you can like really
move your weight around
and always kind of keep your weight
above either the back tire or the front
tire or wherever it needs to be
is it full suspension full suspension it
goes over bumps
like nothing it's kind of scary how
smooth it is
uh and i'm worried i'm gonna get really
overconfident really fast in that thing
and then just have a hard crash
because i feel like crashes are worse on
bikes yeah they can be is it like a
single uh suspension on the back
or it's kind of how do they do it's
weird so it's like if you imagine the
back tire of a bike there's basically
uh two pieces of metal that go to a
point on the axle
uh and those two pieces of metal that
connect like the bottom and the top of
like your seat
uh rod so you know you're sitting on
like a vertical rod with a seat on the
top that's where the seat of the bike
goes
that makes up one side of the triangle
and then the point that triangle is
meeting at the axle the back tire
so basically they took both of those
points of that triangle that meet the
seat rod
and one the bottom one pivots then the
top one's like on a
shock so basically your back tire can
rotate
from the center of the bike um and the
big idea is that when you're what's the
big idea the big idea is that when
you're going down a hill or you're going
along
uh you know flat terrain and you're
really putting some power into it and
pedaling the idea is that as you go over
bumps it's constantly pushing the tire
back down into the ground to keep that
traction going the whole time
so it's not really there to make it so
your ride is comfy and smooth it's there
to keep the tire pushing into the ground
even when it would be bouncing up or
otherwise hitting divots
the downside of having suspension on
your back tire and by the way there's a
lot of great comments in the last
video where we talked about the bikes so
thank you to everybody who commented and
gave me advice i actually it was i read
everything was really useful
um but you know the thing is when you're
peddling up a hill
and you're putting a lot of power in
that bike and pushing down that
suspension is going to squish a little
bit every time and take some of that
power away from you
so for example higher end suspensions
have a little switch you can flip and it
locks the whole thing
if you want to for climbing up your
heels which is really cool this bike has
that
but it doesn't need it because it has a
motor on it
so you know it's already a nice mountain
bike it's pretty cool
i didn't know everything could be so
light and so tight and so quick like the
gears it's just like
a little click and then it shifts and
you can't even feel it it's like it's
nuts like high tolerances
yeah everything's really tuned in and
like can't remember who's
talking to me about this you might have
mentioned this run but you know
bikes have a lot of components on them
which is kind of why they also get
expensive so quick
but cheap components break down and so
you don't be sitting there fixing
a little fidgety thing on your bike once
yeah you know like a small little
small little plate that's like
proprietary broke in half and it's like
well there's only one place i can buy
this again
yeah i really wanted to avoid cheaply
made um
and the other cool thing is that the uh
so the frames it's a it's a really
high-end frame but
it's you know bikesdirect.com this is
not a sponsorship it's
i that's where i got my last bike from
basically it's a place to get cheap
bikes that are really well made and
engineered
it's kind of like getting the uh the
store brand of like cereal where they
both come from the same factory
it's just one doesn't say kellogg's on
it gotcha right right
so it's not totally generic is this
sorry i might have missed it is this an
e-bike this is an e-bike
okay so first let's talk about how good
the bike itself is right
so the whole the whole point is that
there's a dude out here in la that buys
these things and there's this chinese
company named
i guess i don't know how you pronounce
it b-a-f-a-n-g buffeng
they make specific kits that you can put
on any bike
and so they make this really high-end
kit that's super powerful
it's like 800 bucks or something like
that and so there's this guy out here in
california that's
buying those kits and buying like nice
frames off of bikes direct
and he puts those two together and he's
bit like to get that equivalent bike
uh would cost you like 13 000 10 000 8
000 like one of those
kind of insane numbers um but
having this guy do it instead you're
getting you're actually getting a bike
that has better electronics than those
bikes with about
you know around the same quality frame
maybe a little less quality
uh but for you know a third of the price
a quarter of the price like way way
way more affordable um so enough about
the bike we're not here to talk about
the bike we're here to talk about
electronics
because that's the part that's insane so
i assume this is a rear
uh motor it is not a rear motor it is
mid-drive it is mid-drive yes
and so this is a hard concept i tried to
explain this to a lot of people i must
be doing a really bad job of it because
everybody kind of looks at me like uh
when i try to explain this but
so if you imagine the motor of a car you
know you can give it some gas and it
spins faster
but that's that's all the output you get
is whatever that motor can give you in
that spin
but if you want to turn change take that
motor and turn it to like into say
like high speeds like for the highway
driving you need to use gears
to change the output of your motor spins
into a different spinning rate for your
tires
likewise if you're like a truck and you
want to start like pulling something in
like a really low gear
you might want to put a lot of motor
spins into just a few tire spins so
you're putting a lot of power behind the
spins
so basically a transmission lets you
transform a motor into either a lot of
power
or a lot of speed and you really don't
get both unless you just have the
beefiest motor in the system
um so a bike that has a motor on the
tire
the motor is going to be able to put out
whatever it has to offer juice wise and
that's it there's no way to turn that
power into
speed or using mechanical advantages
using the mechanical advantage of gears
but
he's he's got a mid-drive mechanical
advantage it will
so here's the thing the bike already
comes with 12 gears and it's not like
the bike where like three of those gears
on the front and like six are in the
back or whatever
it's 12 rings of gears on the tire on
the back of the bike
okay yeah that's a lot it's a lot and
i've never seen that before until
actually looking at mountain bikes
exactly i was gonna say like mountain
bikes i know like i had like a six gear
one but that was like
that was pretty like oh that's fancy
yeah
it doesn't have the it doesn't have the
rings in the middle
no it does just on the back it has 12
individual rings on the back
so uh also i guess when we're talking
about mid-drive basically imagine
putting the motor between the pedals
exactly yes between the pedals so
basically
you know just like how the gears on the
bike let you change your foot power to
be
towards you know going up heel and
you're pedaling you know really fast the
bike goes really slow but you have a lot
of push power or you know you're going
down the flat road really fast and
you're
you know you change that power so that
you're turning into speed it's the same
thing
you know putting the motor on the middle
of the bike it's letting you
change like that you know through
mechanical advantage you're changing the
output of the motor to do different
hybrid hybrid e-bikes yeah really cool
so because it's a normal mountain bike
low gear for example low gear is bigger
than the gear that you pedal
uh so it's basically you're getting less
turns of the tire than you are turns
your feet which means you have a lot of
power into that tire
the motor on this bike is a 1600 watt
motor
the motor on the onewheel xr is a 750
watt motor
so this thing is putting out like twice
the power of an xr
and then i have gears on top of that to
make it seem
that the bike tire is actually rotating
less for every rotation of the motor
which means i have so much torque in
that thing
that i can do a wheelie going up the
verdugo mountain
like on one
can you do it on flat ground i can do oh
yeah like
you have to be careful because
well i mean if you're going up a hill
that's easier to do a wheelie
but more of the point that you're
starting from
yeah you can do it on the ground very
you can like literally just you push the
throttle in the lowest gear and the
thing
snaps out from under you to the point
where i'm kind of worried about the
chain like
you know you can if you pedal it doesn't
snap out from under you when you hit the
throttle it goes full throttle you know
uh but like in fact because there's
gears you have like this added
responsibility
of taking care of your bike whereas if
you're running the motor
and you're in a really high gear and you
stress it out and it like it is pulling
with all its might it's putting all that
into the chain
you can actually stretch the chain so
you need to make sure you're in an
appropriate gear for what you're asking
the bike to do you don't be trying to
rev it up a hill in a high gear at the
same time you're gonna
you know the motor's gonna work as hard
as it possibly can and all that force
goes into the chain
but compared to like the one wheels for
example like
i so there's a part on verdugo verdugo's
the mountain that we uh frequently ride
up here in los angeles it's one of the
tallest peaks within the city
it's right above burbank and glendale
yeah i believe it's like what 4 400
feet not quite that high it's a little
lower than that
yeah a good chunk though i mean you can
see there's not a higher peak except for
the mountains
like the actual mountains that created
the desert um
so going up that under one wheels we can
maybe average eight miles an hour
or so maybe six miles an hour on the
steeper parts well
some of us so this bike lifts at 20
going uphill it's crazy
like it's sk it's dangerous like how
fast you can actually go like you don't
have to of course floor it but like
this power that it has is nuts and like
when i have a device
i like to not always be using that thing
at maximum right like if you have an air
conditioner and you're running it at
maximum 24
7 it's not a it's not a powerful enough
air conditioner for what you need it for
you know it's like if you have an
electric vehicle
and you're running it at maximum all the
time it's not fast enough when you're
running it at half and you're like this
is comfortable
and you know that you have that headroom
that's a really good feel dude when i
had my nissan leaf and i just had and i
had to floor it just to go down the
highway
your pedals all the way to the ground
yeah
like hope i don't have to pass anyone
[Laughter]
yeah so it's it's pretty crazy like i'm
really looking forward to riding this
bike a whole bunch
it's it's a dirt bike it's basically a
dirt bike it has the power of like you
know a smaller dirt bike
but it's on a bike frame and it weighs
like 50 pounds so the most important
question
that i'm wondering about what are the
specs of the battery
the battery all right so random i've
gone up to the top of verdugo
and back down from my house which is you
can't you can maybe do that on an xr
battery if you weigh like 130 pounds
i did that on the bike already plus
another trip like halfway up and down
and the indicator still says full
also that's not a spec it's not fair
it's 52 volts
13 amp hours okay okay that's a solid uh
okay that's a that's a half kilowatt
hour yeah a little over
does it recharge when you go downhill no
okay does it not really no huh cause it
doesn't have that resistance right yeah
okay that would make sense
yeah you would get that in a direct
drive uh yeah
and you could probably get that if if
you had like the rear tire motor but i
guess
in the mid drive where you have you know
like when you're riding a bike and you
stop moving the pedals and you hear that
yeah it's like the single drive gear of
the bike pedals that's why you can't
really like
i mean i guess you can move backwards
but when you when you go
forwards they catch the gears and they
go but there's no
you can yeah there's nothing if it goes
backwards unless you're like not hard
energy back into the battery alas but
the
elasticity no i don't need it though i
mean but at the end of the day these are
all just vehicles
for freedom especially freedom of the
city freedom like
i've always wanted to make a uh or i
i've always wanted a 72 volt
electric man i ran into a guy randomly
up on that verdugo hill he built his own
e-bike yeah like this big thing you like
put it together with like struts and
stuff
72 volts is a lot of juice yeah yeah
here's a
72 volts this is a big one there's a lot
of 20 cell battery
there's a lot of wilderness in los
angeles but it's not really accessible
wilderness because it's mountain
wilderness
but it's true wilderness like you know
like i think it says before the biggest
municipal park in the world is in los
angeles it's griffith park it's a
mountain it's an entire
it's actually multiple mountains and
there's nothing on them
but you can't just like hey you wanna go
hang out on the top of a mountain cool
let me just
you know pack food for six hours and
then get up there and then
yeah about an hour before you have to
get back down
yeah and the onewheels and to the point
this electric bike
have made it where going to the top of
the mountain is a 20-minute
i literally don't have to work like you
just you have to be of course you have
to be aware so you don't drive off the
mountain and kill yourself but like
beyond that it's like walking down to
your park to have a picnic but you're on
top of mountain instead
okay yeah so nico um
coincidentally along the lines of
electric powered
devices did you buy tesla no
no the uh he said yes that would have
blown my mind
the ford f-150 lightning just uh oh yes
so i put in a reservation for one of
those
um because they seem pretty badass i
still have to do a little bit more
research you know before i
commit to it but of course um coolest
thing about it
uh if your house
does not yes if your house does not have
power you can use your car
to charge your house or to power your
house that's really cool
yeah that's definitely the future we're
going for and actually that's that's the
theory i put out there behind the cyber
truck and i guess ford beat tesla to it
was that the cyber truck was basically
going to double as a power wall for your
house
all testers technically can they also
don't give you that ability and because
they don't quite have the capacity i
would argue
they can they're getting close i mean
when you say capacity are you talking
about
the amount of energy well i mean they
could but it's more like
if you supply juice to your house you
would start to really cut into like if
you need to drive the car
like somewhere like because you know
it's like you get
realistically 200 something miles to a
charge whereas like if your car had 600
miles on it's like who cares if you run
the house for a day or two off that
thing
you know well that's the assumption
though i mean i i don't know
that much about the lightning the ford
lightning uh what
range are they advertising for it the
the
the base model uh has 230 miles
and then you can upgrade to a 300 mile
okay so max of 300 miles do you happen
to know what the energy capacity is in
kilowatt hours
uh no i read through that when i was
reading through all the information but
it
did those numbers still don't quite
register with that's totally fine that's
totally fine
i guess what i'm saying is that like you
know a tesla like the model 3 has a 75
or 80 kilowatt hour battery
and that's a huge battery like the power
walls that
uh people get are like 10 to 15 kilowatt
hours and how much is a tesla
how much is it testing no sorry in
kilowatt hours was it 80 you said yeah
75 or 80. it's in that range
like the long range model so 80 000 watt
hours and the one wheel correct for
example is 360 watt hours correct
so that's a lot of one wheel batteries
yeah it is yeah
wow no and i forget the specific reasons
but you can totally power a house for a
few days off of
uh off of just a regular tesla but it
has to do with the actual like charging
infrastructure
uh yeah that we have currently for
to charge your car like you plug your
car into the wall it's not really built
to take that charge
back so if you want to charge your your
house from your truck you're gonna have
to get a specific
charger that can power your house from
your truck right and that's just not
something tesla sells
which i definitely will at some point um
i'm also thinking about putting solar
panels down in the field
down there because then i can yeah um
so it says it has peak charging power of
19.2 kilowatt hours enabled by the
battery's dual on-board chargers
which means a full charge overnight is
that does that sound
oh that's just how it can charge that's
not the right number let me
no yeah yeah that was a charging rate
okay let me
look it up so i'm curious jake what drew
you to the
lightning which by the way i can't
believe no one took the term lightning
for their vehicle until now
i know ford's like hey how about the
lightning it's like no that's too
obvious somebody must have taken the
lighting i mean there's the leaf there's
a tesla there's
it's like wait a minute there isn't a
lightning wait a second nobody's taken
lightning yet
i wonder how much of it plays into they
can't use certain terms because they've
already have a
a like a catalog of names that they've
pre-trademarked
i think ford would have trademarked
lightning though that sounds like a ford
car to me
so jake why uh why the lightning and not
the cyber truck
i mean nico jake just laughs no
seriously
do i have to explain uh well
okay i'll like you know like that
chromeboy
the basic answer is that like the pos
what do you think the possibility
is the probability is that whoever
designed the cyber truck
actually uses a truck
[Laughter]
fair point and then the other thing is
is they tried to make it all like
you know it's like it's completely
impractical for an
actual work truck practical i'm actually
curious
because specific what are those side
things like
the the angled things on the bed
you don't want that on your bed you want
a flat you want a flat thing so you can
put stuff on top of it or add like
uh rigging to it or like you know
get get over the side of the truck for
access to the bed
i think there's all these and then the
other thing is they didn't try to like
redesign it and be like
you know let's make it all like they're
just like
same truck electric motor and now you
have a front truck and all this other
cool stuff
wait are you talking about the lightning
now yeah oh okay yes
yeah so so that was that was the other
thing plus
i've i've always like had fords
so i'm just comfortable with them as
machines
i mean they've been making trucks for a
very long time they've got a lot of
truck experience
they do have a lot of truck experience
um so so that was another reason
um very competitive costs on the
lightning as well i
don't know what the cyber truck starts
at but
um i think they say it starts at like 38
or something like that okay
so that that's that's about the same for
these these start at like 40.
yeah huge asterisk with what i said aka
the thing doesn't exist yet and won't
exist for another two or five years
that was the other thing too is like i
don't know when
like ford's saying that they're gonna
start actually delivering these sometime
next year
and that you can actually start ordering
them at the end of this year
um so i don't who knows if that's you
know
true or not but um that was another
reason
the main marketable advantage that tesla
has over everyone else is the technology
you know it's like
they have a battery factory that is way
more advanced than any other battery
factory in the world
and on top of that they're also actually
putting like modern day
smart tech in the car which you know no
one else is really doing
quite yet like everyone's kind of
getting there but they're they're so far
behind in terms of like self-driving
capabilities behind tesla
they will all get there soon enough i
imagine in about 10 years
most cars will have pretty decent at
least highway
self-driving capabilities um
but yeah i mean ten years okay so rem
this is a guess
i'm just saying for a wide enough to
where every single car that you're
getting these days yes the fleet cycles
every 20 years or so
yeah i mean yeah and this is a guess on
kilowatt hours it's saying on the
standard
range battery 115 to 125
kilowatt hour total and that's the 200
okay that's for 230 and then the
and then 155 to 170 damn
on the extended range battery those are
huge batteries
okay so if we just say 150 the truck
weighs six or
six thousand pounds 100 miles
yeah wow just batteries torque on that
thing layers
insane dude and okay so the fastest like
truck
right now is the raptor and that thing i
don't know
what it does 0 to 60 but this thing just
the standard like
basic model like smokes it you know just
because it's electric
yeah um so yeah it's got i mean does it
have multiple motors or
is it yes yes dual motors
front and back and then the batteries
center
on the on the bed you know in the middle
in the middle of the frame
yeah um so yeah big battery by the way
yeah 150 kilowatt hours oh my god
yeah it's two teslas yeah
yeah so i just want most of the weights
coming from something like that
seems like it's going to be a monster i
think i feel like almost any electric
vehicle puts
to like just totally dominates like the
gas equivalent in terms of like the
specs it's hard to argue that there's
like a gas-powered version of something
that's better than the like electric
version of something when it comes to
like
motor output yeah the only honestly the
only
advantage non-electric vehicles still
have over electric is the ability to do
long-range travel yeah and easy like
refills that don't require the vehicle
to travel to a refill station
but you can still rent a car if you want
to do that
sure i guess i'm just saying it's like
you can you can stop to refill your car
for about you know two to five minutes
or whatever and you get back on the road
and keep going
and that just gets more and more intense
the bigger your vehicle like
if you're trying to put 200 gallons into
your truck you know it takes a long time
to you know fill 200 gallons but then
you're also able to go
hundreds of miles if you're trying to do
that equivalent with electricity
charging
you're gonna be sitting there for quite
a long time that's why when tesla
introduced the semi
they also introduced the mega chargers
which
are super high voltage and also super
high current
to the point that they actually have
four different plugs within the
connector
each one is a parallel plug just so that
they don't have the voltage go up too
high because at a certain point
a voltage when the voltage gets high
enough it actually arcs through the
rubber
of the charger and oh god
yeah that would destroy somebody and as
it is i think the tesla's run at like
something like two or three hundred
volts maybe 400
i'm not exactly sure as well so and then
and then one other thing that
that sort of convinced and all i did was
make the reservation which was just a
refundable 100
oh nice um so you can see the other
thing
is the uh the batteries are are
recyclable is what it says
interesting well i don't know if that's
true or not
we're just talking about that i mean it
is true here's the thing
all lithium ion batteries are
technically recyclable it's just that
no one really has an established process
for doing it and at volume
at scale you know uh that is on
the the docket for the gigafactory they
have an entire section of the building
dedicated to just ingesting used
batteries breaking them down into their
components
and then reusing them but that's what's
the awesome thing about lithium ion
batteries is that like
if you actually just break down the
components and rebuild them it's a brand
new battery
you can reuse all the same components
it's just it's just an
orientation thing that gives the energy
and
it's like slowly becomes unoriented that
which is the degradation of the battery
you know as opposed to other fuel
sources where it might be like reusable
to some extent but not quite as well
yeah but there's if there's money to be
made in it people will figure it out
although uh jb uh i forget the dude's
name
uh one of the lead engineers at tesla
for the longest time actually quit tesla
j jb jb stradwell or something like that
i'm blanking on his name dang it
he quit tesla he was like lead of
engineering for the last you know 15
years
to start a battery recycling company
um so if ford is saying that their
batteries are going to
be recyclable part of me thinks that's
just marketing
um yeah they're just like oh our
battery's going to be recyclable
like in 10 years you have to be able to
say that you know
but tesla's saying the same thing
they're saying their batteries are
recyclable
you know okay but they're not actually
recycling them yet they're just reusing
them
right uh when you retire an electric car
what happens is that that battery is now
a perfect stationary battery for like a
building
oh like uh like a power wall exactly
interesting interesting wait what what
do you mean stationary battery
like parent like you know like plug a
battery into a building power the
building
because you know like you do the whole
thing about like battery degradation
right
now i need to recharge my house over
time i just want to charge my house with
my car
where's the big usb plug yeah where is
the usb
huge mailbox slot just like
man yeah uh i mean i guess what i'm
saying is that you get a battery
or you get some sort of electrical
device computer
phone car one wheel uh it's got a fresh
new battery it
goes really far and then over time as
you recycle or as you recharge it over
and over and over again
over dozens or hundreds of recharges you
don't get that full capacity you start
getting down to like 90
then 80 maybe even as low as 70 percent
typically around the 80 mark a battery
is considered
end of life and so it gets replaced
uh in whatever devices and the thing is
though is that
you know and a 100 kilowatt hour battery
at 80 degradation is still an
80 kilowatt hour battery yeah there's
still a lot of energy there
uh they just it's not really feasible
for a vehicle anymore so you can remove
it and now
use it to power anything else there's
still a tremendous amount of energy
there
it just doesn't make as much sense from
like an energy to weight perspective
yeah it's not your that's what you
need you need to not be worried about
density yeah
exactly exactly and that's but that's
yeah grid storage is still kind of a
thing
when you know density is not really that
big of a deal so you have older battery
technologies that still kind of work
because you have all the space you need
to have all the energy you want
we are so we are seriously diving into
energy and battery and
stuff again welcome back to the quarter
cast now broadcast is actually
not that secretly a futurology podcast
because honestly that's what got us into
filmmaking in the first place
we were all futurologists when it came
to filmmaking so
speaking of futurology i made a big
shift yesterday i made a
big life change really a big
big change you're not going to ride a
onewheel ever again
how dare you suggest something like that
even as a joke
no i got a macbook i got i got a i got a
little laptop here
um what get that thing out of here i
have mine
getting those files off of there i
didn't see it coming i gotta admit
i have been a pc user my entire life i
have never once owned a mac
or macintosh or macbook or any type of
mac computer
in the 28 years of computer using i've
been doing for someone who likes tech so
much
that's super surprising to me is it
though because
from my point of view max have always
been a little not customizable enough
yes but the ui uh and the the
tangibility and just like sleekness
has always been the price of those
components
never really seemed to work to me i'm
not going to argue and those ads when
they're like
i'm not going there we released it in
purple now
isn't that cool yeah i don't know for me
on that one i never considered having
more than one computer and i was like
all right if i'm gonna have a computer
it's gotta be a pc
pc is powerful configurable you can you
can
build a pc that's as powerful as a mac
for a third of the price
type deal you know uh with that you know
are obviously like
classic pc problems um but
i i started realizing that i would love
to be able to use my computer from my
bed or my couch so if i had like a cheap
little laptop to be able to parsec into
it it'd be great but then i also started
realizing
over the last decade i've slowly become
a bit of an apple boy you know i
i got an ipad i got an iphone
last summer i got an apple watch and i
realized
i want to come back to the live
[Laughter]
i want to be able to just airdrop files
from my phone to my laptop
there was a hole i want to be able to
answer text messages on my laptop
yeah and you're right
you know it's like there isn't like a
windows laptop that has a good battery
life but
this isn't i've never used a windows
laptop that can have the battery last
longer razer has entered the chat
what so
do you know how long the battery so this
is the is that the m1
the m1 chip the m1 is insane and it's
the macbook air
it's the not the base model but the one
up so it doesn't have like 16 gigs of
ram but it does have a half terabyte ssd
it's basically an ipad with a keyboard
and a different operator yes it's a 1200
laptop it's you know not cheap but
compared to other
mac laptops those usually start at like
2 000 2500 if you want something decent
and this the the battery life on this
thing take a guess
eight hours 18.
18 hours of battery life for a laptop
that's insane
have you ever seen the internals of a
macbook air by the way no
so the the internals of the macbook air
are basically the same internals as your
phone and the ipad
in other words if you look at your phone
and you like you look at half of your
phone that's like you know chips and the
other half is basically battery i mean
it's not quite laid out like that but
so if you look at the macbook air and
how big that is basically just imagine a
small like
four inch by four inch square in the
center that's all the hardware
and then all the rest of it is battery
oh wow
yeah so it's basically just one giant
battery
[Laughter]
on your lap there are some of those like
internet surfer books
that uh have really good battery life
like the pixel book
and yeah microsoft has that
um i don't know there's another one that
they have those those both had i've had
both of those they had good battery life
but
they're not pcs they are not pcs they're
they're basically tablets with keyboards
yeah you can't have no access to file
systems like you get you get the tried
and true
os x operating system yeah
and i've been using an ipad for last
year or so and i
i love the ipad it's great but at the
end of the day as much as i
try to make it a laptop replacement it
is just
not the file system on the ipad is
god-awful and
like i i needed that i needed a computer
yeah
and this is this is a computer well you
got one yeah congratulations
although you know it's funny because i
got home i was so excited i picked it up
from the store i got home
opened it up out of the box booted it up
initialized it with my information all
that stuff
and it goes to the desktop i'm like all
right i'm this is the moment this is the
moment i've been waiting for i finally
get to use the laptop and i'm like
i have no idea how to use this i do not
know what to do
i was just like uh oh
right this is not a pc and so i ended up
having to watch
how to use a macbook tutorials
you can ren you can um uh
parcel your hard drives uh to have it
it's like
windows yeah so so i used to have an
i uh uh macbook when i was in law school
and we had to take the bar exam on a pc
program so i parse i parcel you
partition part of my
partition that's the word yeah half of
my drive
to like commit to that and it was it was
fine
yeah when i was in college actually all
of our engineering computers at the
school were
were those mac towers you know like the
big ones but they all ran windows
that was so funny yeah wow uh
and yeah honestly the main reason why i
got this was that i can use parsec
to connect to my computer from my bed
parsley is pretty amazing
it is yeah it is incredible
i hate to say it but i feel like i feel
like you know all the like uh
the cloud-based computing stuff you know
it's out there
um i feel like you know everybody thinks
that that's the future because why i
need a powerful computer at home you can
just use them on the cloud
but that's actually kind of
short-sighted because you just extend
that future out like a few more years
and that computer that you're connecting
to on the cloud you can have at home for
a couple
bucks and why not just have their
computer in your the corner of your
house
in a little box and now you don't have
any latency to worry about you don't
have any
you know internet foiable story but you
can still connect to it from your tiny
little podunk laptop or computer or
whatever
you want in the rest of the house but
you know like
the m1 chip in your macbook air is an
insanely powerful chip
in three or four years that chip's gonna
be the slow boy you know it's like
so what if they had a little box that's
just in the corner your house and that's
you know that's the computer that you
log into rather than having to always
connect to the cloud oh cause then that
computer will also get out of date i
think the idea behind cloud services is
that
you know they're constantly getting
updated you're paying for a service to
always have the top of the end
computer i think there's merits to both
that's true absolutely i'm
on board with just having the
workstation at home i don't want to use
someone else's computer which is in
essence what a cloud computer is google
stadia still around
technically it is
about how google stadia was going under
they're canceling it and all this stuff
and then there's all this news like no
they're still working on it they're
still okay
we have high sites for it
we should do an entire podcast dedicated
to
all of the all of the products that
google has attempted to create
that are like sitting in a drawer
somewhere
we have a variety of those in our
drawers
we don't have any google glass though
that's true because they're really
like i think the hardware is really
expensive and they didn't really give
them out i remember brandon or someone
who worked with brandon back in the
early stress level zero days had one so
i tried it on
i tried rather i tried it out and
whatnot and i was like i can see why it
didn't catch on immediately
immediately i get why no one wants this
without even having to use it
imagine having to use siri for 100 of
your interactions with your phone
except it's like a tenth of as good as
theory
yeah and i i i guess i understand the
eventuality of that tech you know but
like
in in it in the google glass iteration
it was like
literally this tiny little window like
the size of like
like literally a postage stamp at arm's
length
yeah like that was the size of the
screen that you could
see through the glasses smaller than the
hollow lens was
yeah hololens was pretty cool though
hololens like as a concept
like obviously the hardware wasn't quite
there yet but the thing that was really
neat about it was
being able to put your screens up
anywhere in your space
and like having it remember that space
so you can put it on any moment and look
back to the wall where your like virtual
tv is and always have the virtual tv be
there
and like that's really forward thinking
because imagine in like 10 years and the
hardware is really good
and you have your tv sitting on the
virtual wall and you have your virtual
sculpture in like the front of your
house and
you know you have your virtual art
hanging on the walls oh yeah
yeah would you like to have that all
going on in your house nico
you know yes of course i feel like i
feel like of course i would man
yeah they are holograms all over my
house like for real
do you think
[Laughter]
you can display all your my collection
have nfts and
seen those new uh the the snap glasses
snap what's the name of snap snap chat
yeah sorry yes snapchat they just
released new spectacles
uh my friend don uh was on the cover
of wired magazine for those he was
wearing their
new brand new spectacle glasses uh that
have like an ar display built in
apparently they're pretty decent i know
very little about them though
yeah it's a little sketchy though having
people wear cameras while they're
looking at you
yeah yeah it's a little weird what's
snapchat up to these days how's their
stock doing let's find out
[Laughter]
oh snapchat i don't know honestly i've i
find out i tried getting into snapchat a
little bit
back when we did it actually
significantly since the beginning of
this year
and never touched this is everybody
every stock has all those glasses
well it's all snapchat glasses flying
off the shelves
maybe snapchat's just really holding on
to like i don't know would be like 20 to
25 year olds now
it's like there's one sliver of like
yeah generation that's like snapchat i
know a lot of people are younger than me
than
that still frequent that app yeah well
they did just spend
500 million dollars to buy the company
that made those spectacles
yeah wow they're really investing in
that man
okay who knew you know you know who else
went public
the other day was is uh squarespace and
this is not an
ad seriously you guys know jake
did you buy some squares yeah
we have to introduce it so to not
trigger the audience into thinking it's
an ad
no squarespace went public jake do you
have more information about that
yeah they went they went public uh i
think
last week on like monday
i bought some on uh friday
and uh yeah it's i mean they started
they they entered at 50 they went down a
little bit
now they're up at 55. i feel like
they got a long there's a long way to go
there hopefully but
i bought roblox stock when that came out
when he felt bad man like when they when
roblox went public i bought some roblox
stock
i just like screw it did they get
massively popular before or after before
okay okay because they're
one of those it's a game but it's also
kind of like i've never played it right
i mean i mean
i played it a little bit with my nieces
uh who are super into it they're like
you know like
six and eight years old actually no they
might be like ten now i don't know
they're young
um i never realized how
massively huge it is yeah it's how many
millions of people
it's the vr system from ready player one
it's just they don't have vr headsets
yet yeah
it's like in time that's what it will
become interesting it like blew my mind
when i started realizing the reach of it
was kind of like you know
five ten years ago when you started
realizing how many
people played minecraft yeah you're like
oh wow that mini
and just like every year just got bigger
and bigger and bigger
like i went through phases over the
course of the last decade of like i'd
play a bunch of minecraft for a while
and then like
fall out of it for a couple years play a
bunch fall out of it for a couple years
so what are their what's their top game
roblox
yeah roblox roblox it is a game it's
like minecraft
dude sorry i you this is not my i don't
play it i don't know i don't know man
no i mean like it's it's a game like
playing a really far
world it's an open-ended world game
platform type thing you can
make games within it so cool when did
you buy it nico
like right when they went public oh so
like a couple weeks ago
it was more than a couple weeks ago or
something like that yeah so you
you just made a bunch of money in the
last like three days oh hell yeah
you bought it around 70. let me check
it's up at 90 now
wow hopefully i bought it at 70. yeah i
mean it's just one of those things where
it's like
the idea of having a a game environment
where it's about
being within that game environment and
making more games and figuring out a way
to
enable that i mean everybody everybody
pursues that user generated content but
i don't think
that's the thing i think about gaming in
general they lack
good really good social experiences in a
way that you get that with dungeons and
dragons because you can only craft so
many gameplay experiences before like
you know the group of artists and game
designers you have making that like they
can only put stuff out so fast
obviously you can have user generated
content but it kind of sucks if people
are just doing it for fun you know it's
like you don't really get that much good
stuff
i'm kind of surprised that they don't
have
the equivalent of like disney park
disney like disneyland theme park
mascots get getting paid to be
in the games like not quite npcs cause
they're actual people
but they're not player characters either
they're there
being paid and whether it's in credits
in the game or in real money or whatever
they're being paid to be in that world
to be there for you to fight or to run
the game or to direct things to try to
make it as fun as possible like wow
okay what if for example you're playing
games of battlefield but there was a
overall war director who's not on either
team
and they just try to make the whole
battle fun and interesting by like
changing certain things by adding
certain things etc
and at the end of the game if you liked
it you leave them a little tip or a
little like thumbs up and whoever
has enough thumbs ups at the end of the
day gets like 10 bucks
you know or something like that i don't
know i'm just throwing it out there but
like video games
they're like a blackjack dealer yeah
yeah exactly
video game companies don't have players
being incentivized to like be
dms or like the villain or something
like that like
what if you went into a dungeon and the
the villain was just another player but
they're
they're not there to win they're there
to be the villain to get killed by you
and they're getting paid from the game
to do so interesting idea yeah
so roblox has hints of that happening
battlefield tried that with like the
general system or whatever i forget what
it's called it's like commander
but you could like use your tablet or
iphone even to like
okay play battlefield games and
literally like
i mean it's not very extensive you can
like have some perks
some abilities and you can set
objectives for the team
but i mean still there is that feeling
of like okay there's someone kind of
watching
over us like helping the flow of the
game kind of form
so that that was kind of a cool system
so
no i agree that'd be cool i bought
roblox at 69
i've made 300.
baby
i did not buy very much roblox hopefully
hopefully it's
not one of those reddit stocks yeah man
i don't i don't buy individual stocks to
actually try to make money off them i
just
i buy them because who knows what will
happen in the future i just buy them
because i like to like
lean my overall investments towards some
stuff once in a while
like yeah nvidia and tesla are like
the two companies i actually have like
anything significant
way back in the day we're talking like
when i was still running the behind the
scenes channel i remember you
you and sam both bought tesla stock i
think sam got in at around 70
and you tried getting in at 90 but it
was like the end of the day
and so it auto purchased the next
morning at like a hundred
and five dollars i think and i remember
you being kind of pissed like man i
didn't get in on time
and now it's too high it's never gonna
get higher than this and like
you're like i'll probably sell in a
couple weeks and like i forget what
happened you ended up selling it a
little bit later maybe you'd gotten up
to like a 1
30 or something like that and you ended
up selling it all i ended up selling it
all and ended up buying it back in later
i'm like i'm just gonna ride it now and
then i actually sold
i sold a chunk to get the actual tesla
and i sold a chunk about
a month ago when it was at 6 45 and it
was dipping i'm like okay
this wild ride this bubble is going to
pop at some point this is wild red
and it wasn't like i'm just going to say
that i just took it out i'm going to put
on the mattress i'm just going to put it
i put the money into more like less
risky investments because it's like
tesla is risky
it's made a bunch of money it's still
hella volatile and risky
and i was kind of getting tired of
having that much money exposed to risk
so i started yeah the emotion
the emotion of it yeah but dude i bought
take two interactive at
fourteen dollars a share and sold at
like twenty eight dollars a share or
twenty six dollars a share
jake can you look at what take two is
that right now let's yeah let's see
because i was like gta 5's coming out
soon it's probably gonna do really well
wait how much did you buy it for
i bought it for 14 dollars i sold it for
it's at 184
i should have held it i should have
sold it i was thinking short no no yeah
that would have paid for the entire bike
for free
[Laughter]
man anyways that was like when i thought
i could use my my gamer sense is like
inside knowledge like this game is going
to do great
and it did do great and then i've
neglected how much money they would make
on gta online sold long before that
happened
man yeah yeah well uh
speaking of tech that we bought i bought
a nutribullet blender the other day oh
yeah
i'm pretty stoked about that bullet
blender you're blending some stuff
what's your water turns that fruit into
juice real quick let me tell you what's
your favorite blends oh let me tell you
the lip blenders are no gel i just had
to chime in with my my recent tech
purchase
it's rose gold you know it's rose gold
is it really i'll have you know
yeah no but those things are like
macbooks and blenders they're pretty
sleek
aluminum chassis is it is it's all it's
all machined
yeah premium price it's the macbook of
blenders let me tell you
wait you said nutra blender uh
the the magic bullet i had a magic
bullet back in the day
it was it was nice but i hated the
cleanup
because it was like any blender name one
that's part of the life dude you have to
get in there
wrist blades we just discovered a new
market that we can get into the clean
the self-selling
blender yes yeah it needs like a little
bit of water and jet that like shoots
and like it
the the blades spin and like
self-cleaning i mean i guess you could
just like put a little bit of water and
soap back in the blender and then
turn it on that's literally what i what
i did
that's two that's too manual too manual
no one's gonna buy it
yeah um but yeah so that was a bit of a
splurge
no but i actually have been eyeing a new
macbook i still have my imac from 2013.
did christian just whisper same
nice what are you guys dude i've been a
mac boy though since
beginning that's i started as mac boy
unfortunately actually
and uh you know baby dude working here
was the first time i like really had to
learn how to use a pc
um i remember asking nico like hey how
do i like
go to my settings because i didn't know
i like
uh like the editing program was the same
but like i just did not
get less money i use my macbook i was
like how do i go to my
settings how do i find out how much
storage i have
you end up on like some 14 year old
girl's youtube channel who's explaining
this to you
you're like five years ago something's
never changed man
yeah man no i mean i do like apples
uh ui and they're it it's very
just i guess pleasing to the
senses well yeah i went into this
wanting to buy a macbook
uh but not wanting to spend a lot of
money i wanted just something cheap to
complete the echo's ecosystem and to use
parsec with so i was looking at like
maybe a three or four year old
refurbished or used uh macbook
something um like i i don't know
anything about max i just i was like all
right they're usually expensive it's
apple
uh so i'm not gonna get something new
but like with the new m1
chips have brought the price down by
like a factor of
two like they're half as expensive as
they should be now yeah
was it before or after ren that you
realize that they intentionally
downgrade their uh
their hardware after time when you were
like i should probably get a new one
then
[Laughter]
what that came out
like two years ago they they there was
emails leaving no i know i i guess
that's what's happening
one of the higher-ups was talking about
how they intentionally downgrade
their uh their hardware over time so
that people
people want to buy the new one no i
understand that yeah no i'm not
unfamiliar with that uh but it was
specifically the move from away from
intel
chips to these new ones they're so much
more power efficient so much more
so much faster uh let's talk about what
makes the m1 chip special for a second
here
because this is what allows apple to get
away with these
these things that jake's talking about
so i mean
it's it's all about because they make
chips yeah i mean
the fact that they're making it
themselves is like whatever but really
what it comes down to is the integration
of all the components working together
that's why apple's never been about
specs you know like they've never been
like oh we we have four gigs of memory
or ram you have to look for that
information on typically on
on stuff uh they never really advertise
it in their keynote speeches because
like for an iphone for instance you
compare the specs of an iphone to an
android phone
uh an android phone almost every single
time will blow it out of the water
battery size processor speed memory
amount not anymore though
not anymore let's stop with like the
iphone 12. no the iphone 12 pro compared
to a flagship android is still not as
good i can almost swear that
however what i'm getting at is inside
marquis brownlee
him now call him up niko this is his
argument
okay uh and when you get down to it but
you actually start running these
benchmark tests for
battery life and speed of performance
iphone still kind of comes out on top
even though
even with slower processors it's the
fact that apple
controls all of the components from the
operating system to the hardware
they're able to make it work together
it's teamwork that is so
perfect that they're able to get more
output than
the hardware should allow whereas
android
you have all these different companies
making something for one
company that makes the the operating
system
and they're having to source all these
different parts and you end up with like
these little
barriers uh micro barriers all over the
place that slow things down
i can't believe that apple survived like
when you think about that
as like a model especially early
computer i mean they almost didn't
yeah but it's it's pretty remarkable
that
that aspect of it i don't i do not like
though how
they know that there's a faster thing
out there that they could use and they
just
hold on to it until the next generation
of their
hardware comes out but like you said it
doesn't it doesn't matter
um well that's actually the faster thing
isn't actually true anymore with the m1
chip there's like there's actually a
bunch of things that makes it really
special
one they are making it themselves
intel's not making it qualcomm's not
making like they're making it mm-hmm i
don't know much about the machine
learning aspect of it
i know a little bit about the machine
learning i know very little about it too
i just know it has 16
ml cores yeah so
it's also it's i think it's running arm
architecture
so up until this point you have uh you
basically have chips that are
that can run certain types of math and
instructions and you have other chips
that are good for different types of
instructions and the kind of chips that
we have in our pcs
are good at running like actual like
script-based instructions
uh whereas like the stuff like the chips
on your gpu for example are
just good at doing math because gpus
aren't there running through a script
going like okay take this variable and
grab the string now grab this variable
now access this file now grab this very
well and take the string now write this
file like
they're not doing step-by-step
instructions they're doing like all
right take this matrice and multiply by
this matrices like
yeah that's what it does um so up until
this point
the chips that you'd have like on a
phone and the chips that you have on a
computer would be different chips and
then apple just went
screw it they're the same chip and now
they have the same chip
in their computers that they have in
their iphones they have in their ipads
because they reprogrammed os 10 or osx
to run
on arm chips uh so that's crazy that
they can use the same chips in their
phones and their computers
and then on top of that the m1 itself is
like twice as fast
as like the closest competitor chip and
then on top of that
it's heat usage and its electrical usage
or its electricity usage is like
way beyond like what other chips are
like it is so efficient in terms of its
electricity that it
generates so little heat like how many
ports do you have on that macbook air
for uh
preventing none none
there are zero venting vents there are
two usb ports and one
headphone jack and that is literally it
wow
i heard that there's no fan i heard that
the power of that chip is like
equivalent to like
a 1050 or 1060 gpu really yeah
it could be wrong but it's at the point
where it's it's like faster
you can you know you could have graphics
better than you could on the xbox 360.
now they have the power to create a
global ai
deep mind computer kind of because
everybody's
every chip actually has an ai processing
core meant for running like
ai instructions which is oh yeah
yeah yeah it's one of the things that
lets your iphone take such nice pictures
because it's it's running those pictures
through ai
image cleanup i'm still blown away by
how pervasive that is in iphone imagery
it's like
i i know i've mentioned this before i
apologize but in the attack on titan
video there's a segment where i'm
talking about how big people are
and it's one single long take and i shot
it with cam track ar
and that is an awesome app that 3d
camera tracks you're seeing
as it's recording footage but it doesn't
have access to all that machine learning
post processing that apple throws onto
the camera that's why when you take a
picture it looks pretty nice and sharp
you take a video it looks nice and sharp
and stable
but that all happens after the sensor
outputs the image
so cam track ar just gets that output
directly and gives it to you
and so that's why if you actually go
back and look at that video that segment
doesn't look very good it looks like
it's like
it does it does not look good i was
blown away by how crappy the the
footage looked and it was technically 4k
it was no
it may have been 1080 it was like a
weird aspect ratio too but
um yeah there's another shot in that
video where like the bone like
grows and then breaks in half that's
also shot on the same exact phone
but using the the built-in phone
uh camera app and it looks way better
yeah apple saved themselves a bunch of
money
by instead of upgrading their camera
sensors they just created an ai
algorithm to simulate
what it would look like it was shot with
a better sensor it just takes your
worst picture and turns it into the
emulated better picture
and it's amazing how well that works it
works so well
and they have custom silicon on their
chip to make it happen hence the
integrated parts that you're talking
about yeah
yeah yeah it's very smart like if
there's a way to save a lot of money
with like
you know uh software engineering like
that's a way to do it
like i i do actually doubt that i'll
ever get
a mac desktop station i think i'll stick
with pcs for you know forever
maybe i don't know foreseeable future uh
to actually do any amount of work
on um but the new imacs look pretty
sweet like the different colors
but they also straight up just look like
a giant ipad
it's like they're super thin they're
super flat
and they're just they're the size of an
imac and it's because it's like they're
like yeah it's it's because
it is an ipad it's just bigger
it's literally the same all of our
computers now whether it's a
a phone a mini phone a tablet a
laptop or an actual full desktop it's
all the same technology now it's all the
same chipset
it's all the same architecture it's just
a different form factor in different
size
and it's incredible that it's taken us
this long to get there
and only one company has done it
in order to do that is it using a cloud
no it's it's just it's just the chips
are that good
the chips are that good and the software
design is that good too
okay it's it's they've they've
redesigned all ios
osx all that stuff to run on this
chipset no matter what but that's the
beauty of the closed system is
it's like sony making the playstation
you know it's like we know these are the
chips we know this is the hardware
and we're the ones who are going to make
the stuff for it so we're just going to
set the rules and follow them
internally right yeah yeah no there's
definitely value to that and uh
i don't i like to harp on them because
there's there's some things that i don't
agree with but
i mean they do sell everything at a 100
markup over the cost of parts
[Laughter]
yeah have you guys paid attention to the
epic lawsuit at all just a little bit
a little bit yeah i hope epic gets a
solid swing in
i do too yeah i think actually i mean i
actually think epic is a very like
stand-up company and they do a lot of
really good things i 100 agree
yeah yeah and you know the whole concept
of like percentage
taking percentages is kind of [ __ ] up
like
if you have a set cost like you know hey
putting an app in the app store like
okay we have to do these things and to
do this much hosting it's like that's a
set cost
to just say blanket 30 is what we take
like that's not a set cost that could be
like a little bit or it could be a ton
and like to try to argue that
you know well you know
you know let's say you sell like 10
million dollars worth of revenue and
we're gonna take
three million of those dollars like it
didn't cost you three million dollars in
hosting fees
yeah you know you are literally just
arbitrarily saying it says it's a
percentage
they also have a lot of like monopolized
uh
uh practices i guess because it's all on
their platform
and it's their marketplace for those
unaware basically uh epic
uh makes a lot of things that we use
unreal engine for instance they also
make fortnite
and uh these were apps on the app store
for your ipad or iphone
and basically
epic decided to move some of the payment
systems off the platform
off of the apple plus because apple took
30 percent off yeah apple
for every single app that you buy on the
apple
apple pockets 30 of it never never
subscribe to our website on an iphone by
the way
because of that because they just we
just lose 30
immediately yeah and that means you know
i kind of didn't realize that but
i'm not i i know this i understand that
i just didn't
and that's kind of messed up i'm like oh
yeah you're right because they're not
the ones like
it's one thing for like oh we're hosting
the app and you buy the app through our
store we're dealing with the reviews
we're dealing with returns which still
percentage is not a reflection of how
much it actually costs they could just
have a cost number
but like it's like oh if you want to buy
your v bucks for fortnite
we're still going to take 30 of that too
even though now you are handling
yeah and basically all epic did was like
all right if you want to buy like
more v bucks inside the game so you can
buy more skins and whatnot
feel free to you know come to our
website and and buy them there and apple
was like
nah banned banned the app from the webs
from the apple store yeah and apple and
epic was like okay hold on
hold on hell no because they're using
them as an example
for everyone else yeah that's why that's
why there's no merch link
in our app on iphone
because then they'd take 30 of of
whatever else we sell through the store
or
there's some other convoluted nonsense
that we just didn't want to deal with
wow yeah anyway it's interesting
the thing is like apple explicitly
doesn't let you install other things on
the phone
you know it's like you can't get third
party apps they have to go through the
app store no matter
what yeah and that's very monopolistic
and they'll argue well
it's our closed hardware it's like they
have a decent defense for it
it's like you know you want to make sure
everything's secure and uh all that
stuff but it's my device
not yours no yeah for sure but you have
the ability to jailbreak it you know and
you can crack it and whatnot
uh to do what you want but then apple
then kind of turns around and punishes
you for it
yeah arguably this is more of a
monopolistic thing than it is like an
actual like can you or can't you do this
with your phone like
you know of course you can jailbreak
your phone or not jailbreak your phone
like it's more
as a not is it a monopolistic practice
for apple to say
anybody doing anything on our system is
going to give us 30
no matter what regardless of the actual
cost accrued by us or
by them we take 30 percent of everything
because we're the gang that runs the
town
like is that monopolistic you be the
judge
yes it is it is yeah 100
yeah but the news i read uh this morning
was that apparently the apple lawyers
did a much better job presenting their
case than the epic lawyers i was like
okay yeah but who said that
did you read that on apple news
i think it was like verge popped up
apparently some handsome apple lawyers
are articulate and say that okay
very very well converted
it's like they're they they're coming to
some sort of compromise that actually
may end up benefiting apple more
than they were at previously and i'm
like oh well that doesn't
sound good off the top i don't know it's
i don't know anything about it
this is what you get for your insolence
yeah oh man all right
well ladies and gentlemen thank you for
listening to our podcast
it was a good time if you want to hear
us talk about the future and
wax philosophical about iphones tune in
to the code or cast yeah but for real
i talk about videos who knows i promise
i'll only talk about
uh my electric mountain bike a little
bit more
next time we'll play games with an ai
and the time after that we'll someone
will bust an eye
and then next time after that we'll talk
about the future
[Music]
on the corridor chaos
yay are you gonna play us out
post play out yeah i mean i can just jam
on this but
just jam us out and then we'll put this
up put the uh end credit
i'm sure i'll see more comments about
how i talk too much
i mean it's a corridor cast that's why
it's where ren's supposed to talk
[Music]
thanks for listening everyone i
appreciate you tuning in
because three two one